I'm Gabe Delahaye you know max Silvestri
and welcome to our brand new talk show
gaben Max is 100 seconds come out you
live from Central Park on the top of the
Empire State Building top of the rock at
Tavern on the Green which is one of the
hottest restaurants in the world
that's the sort of thing you could learn
by watching our brand new web vlog diary
talk show for details calm it's gonna be
about the newest topics popular culture
hats to buy everything you need gadgets
gadgets for example for the trick with
our show is that every episode is
interviews it's not always well that's
not the trick but every episode is only
one we have over three phone calls out
right now to people to be interviewed on
our new show I don't think that's
impressive but this show is for people
that are on the go they're in a rush if
you're like oh no I got to go my banks
about to close extra views or I could
you know I gotta catch my bus tour with
a bus review it will literally never
have a bank or a bus review might know
if you want to see that watch Gabe and
Gabe Alone's guy yeah Thank You Banksy
this is ah that's not what it's about
it's called gaben maxes 100 gadgets no
seconds it's seconds not gadgets we're
not always going to talk about gadgets
no mostly yet it's not even mostly
gadgets we've done a whole episode we
haven't named one gadget namely gadget
keys key keys or you can just get key
keys are in a catchy
everyone has electronic keys like a
password this is a waste of 100 second